>>> A SHORT TIME AGO, WE HEARD
AIR RAIDIRENS, AN EXPLOSION IN
THE CAPITAL OF KYIV.
WE NOW KNOW, WE BELIEVE WE KNOW
WHAT WAS BEHIND THAT.
OUR CLARISSA WARD IS BACK NOW.
CLARISSA, WE BELIEVE WE KNOW
WHAT THE TARGET WAS OF THAT
ATTACK NOW.
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT, JIM.
SO JUST BEFORE WE HAD SPOKEN
LAST TIME, WE HAD HEARD THAT
LOUD EXPLOSION, AIR RAID SIRENS
THROUGHOUT OUR LIVE REPORT.
WE NOW BELIEVE THAT THE TARGET
WAS THE SORT OF CENTRAL
BROADCASTER TV TOWER.
IT'S ABOUT THREE MILES IN THAT
DIRECTION OVER THAT WAY, AND
WHEN OUR CAMERAMAN WAS ON THE
ROOF, HE WAS ABLE TO SEE A LARGE
PLUME OF SMOKE COMING FROM THAT
DIRECTION.
WE'VE SEEN SOME VIDEOS ALSO ON
SOCIAL MEDIA SHOWING WHAT
APPEARS TO BE LARGE AMOUNT OF
SMOKE.
THE TV TOWER, AT LEAST IN THE
ONE VIDEO WE SAW, APPEARS TO
STILL BE STANDING.
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT THE
STATUS IS OF THAT NOW.
WE HAVE HAD OUR REPORT OUT FROM
THE MINISTER OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS.
THEY SAID THAT THIS, BASICALLY,
THE TV TOWER WAS HIT, THE
CHANNELS WOULD NOT BE WORKING
FOR A WHILE, BUT THAT BACK-UP
BROADCASTING WILL SOON BE
ENABLED.
SO PRESUMABLY, MOST UKRAINIANS
NOT ANY LONGER ABLE TO WATCH
UKRAINIAN MAIN TV CHANNELS.
NOW, IMPORTANT TO PUT THIS INTO
SOME CONTEXT, JIM, THE RUSSIAN
DEFENSE MINISTRY HAD WARNED
EARLIER IN THE DAY THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO BE HITTING SEVERAL
TARGETS INSIDE KYIV IN THE
CAPITAL TODAY AND ONE OF THEM,
WHICH THEY HAD MENTIONED AND
TOLD PEOPLE WHO LIVE NEAR TO
PLACES LIKE THIS TO LEAVE WERE
RELAY NODES, THE LANGUAGE IN
RUSSIAN IS QUITE VAGUE HERE BUT
BASICALLY WHAT WE'VE UNDERSTOOD
THAT TO MEAN IS LARGE SCALE
ANTENNAS, SORT OF COMMUNICATIONS
TOWERS, AND SO THIS APPEARS TO
BE THE FIRST STRIKE TARGETING
THAT, THAT WE NOW SEE ON
UKRAINE'S, ON KYIV'S TV TOWER.
YOU'RE SEEING SOME IMAGES THERE,
AGAIN, OF SMOKE BILLOWING UP IN
THE DISTANCE.
IT WAS A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
EXPLOSION THAT WE HEARD, JIM.
WE'VE OBVIOUSLY BEEN HEARING
STRIKES ON A REGULAR BASIS
THROUGHOUT THE PAST FEW NIGHTS,
BUT THIS WAS LOUDER THAN USUAL.
AGAIN, NOT CLEAR YET WHETHER THE
TOWER ACTUALLY COLLAPSED.
IT APPEARED IT WAS STILL
STANDING BUT OBVIOUSLY SOME
SERIOUS DAMAGE DONE TO THE
SURROUNDING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
UKRAINE'S AUTHORITIES ARE NOW
ANNOUNCING T